and I am done oh my goodness I love it
so much I could just die look at this it
looks so fun
[Music]
one of the ethnic ante Oh
yesterday we uploaded the video where
Casey and I were speaking our languages
so like a trilingual vlog which made me
feel like I cannot mess this one y and
plus you guys really liked it but I'm
actually completely home alone what
yesterday Casey and I went in to go film
JK news and I know what you're thinking
you're like oh my goodness why did you
leave your house I am with you guys but
it's like why did you leave your house
you're supposed to stay at home and be
self quarantine E and yesterday was the
21st day that we had been home or I
guess it reset so I guess 20 complete
days that we were quarantined like fully
110 percent like zero interaction with
anybody from the outside world even with
delivery people you know like they
believe things on the front door and
that's it in terms of me and Casey we
did our part to make sure we are not
sick we haven't gotten anything and art
and Jo they made it a point to be really
careful to also self quarantine
themselves and anyone else who was
involved in the shoot which was Nelson
and nadeem and Bart and Casey and Jo and
so everyone that was in the shoot we all
made sure that everyone was like fully
quarantined since the last time we shot
making sure everyone's healthy and safe
and willing to want to go into the
office to film because our particular
style of filming it's it's really
difficult to just do a zoom style
filming of a hundred videos or more
because we we upload a lot so that's why
the guys decided okay let's go into the
office let's knock some some shoots off
also Bart called the mayor's office to
to make sure like hey is it illegal if
we meet up in like
do this like the poor working and then
the mayor's office said like no you guys
are considered a media outlet which it's
still like conservative essential so so
yeah yesterday we went to go film so
Bart
created a schedule and implemented
people like certain casts to be there
for the next couple days that we're
filming and so Casey got to be there
today but not me
which means I'm home alone and you might
be wondering what happened with Isaac's
so Isaac's dad same thing they have been
fully quarantined and I'm like is your
mom gonna be okay like I don't want her
to feel uncomfortable if Isaac's coming
over or anything and he was like no
we're good everything's good
everything's healthy everyone's healthy
we're doing fine so bring Isaac over so
Isaac is spending the weekend at his
dad's and he's really happy because he
really miss his dad and it's been cute
because they've been facetiming a lot
but it's not the same thing you know
that's what's happening I'm all alone
for the first time in like a long time
today we're supposed to be getting our
blinds installed it's gonna be just one
guy as far as I know it's just one guy
that's coming in installing I'm gonna be
making sure we keep our distance
whatever he touches I would be
disinfecting after like I'm just trying
to take all the precautions necessary
these blinds are actually overdue
because usually they'll they say that it
only takes about two weeks and then they
would install it it's now been like
about a month they were like yeah you
know obviously things are slow so that's
why it has taken this long um but now
we're finally gonna get blinds and you
know more let me use paper fake blind
thingies so I'm excited to get blinds
that's kind of cool
so for downstairs in the living room I
ordered this piece of furniture that we
kind of similar to the armoire a little
bit like it reminds me a little bit
where it has like designs or whatever
it's really cute I really love it it's
supposed to be coming in today
they tried delivering it yesterday but
since we weren't home they couldn't
leave it out in the front because of the
fact that it was raining today luckily
it's not raining so they're probably
gonna leave it out on from the front and
then I just have to figure out how to
bring it in by myself or maybe when
Casey gets home from taking news my plan
is to line the stairs so we went
upstairs and get this thing Wow
so remember how I talked about this
wallpaper going into this bathroom so
turns out I ordered two rolls and my
math was off because the amount of rolls
I I ordered was not enough to cover this
whole wall also the two rolls they
didn't like fully match like the colors
are a little off like the print on one
of them is a little like smaller so it
doesn't fully align so if it's up on a
wall that will drive me crazy so I
decided instead of using this wallpaper
for that wall I'm gonna be using it to
line up the stairs so actually we have a
little example here today where is it
here it is so that's what our stairs are
gonna look like initially I didn't want
to use it for the stairs like this
particular wallpaper because I was
afraid that it was gonna be too girly
though that's why I was just like oh
maybe I shouldn't use it Casey was like
yeah it's not like my most favorite but
you know what I trust you I feel like it
might look good so just go for it we'll
see how it turns out because I was
telling him that the reason why I got
this wallpaper is because I like I like
this piece a lot the cat scratcher
cactus thing would like the pink flowers
and I was like yeah I kind of like ties
it in a bit so if that piece is there
with the stairs it might make more sense
I don't know I actually don't know if I
have enough paper like to complete all
the stairs so we're just gonna have to
find out later today
today is April 10th tomorrow is a
Kitty's birthday so we're gonna be
celebrated somehow I don't know how
because I really don't know how to
celebrate your birthday Maya but
tomorrow's your birthday you are turning
I believe 7 years old you're gonna have
a birthday I like how they're enjoying
the new cat tree oh here's the other one
hi so the old grandpa you're getting
older today I decided to go instead of
coffee because like I'll switch between
coffee and matcha so I'm gonna be making
myself a nice cup of matcha instead
today and not just any much up we're
gonna be doing so don't be don't be much
this thing is so good it is some quality
matcha and I know I'm biased because
Casey and I are involved with Jun be but
I'm also telling you the honest truth
this is some bomb watch up usually the
way you're supposed to do this thing is
you pour so much in here you pour water
in here and then you whisk it with this
thingy you whisk it really well with
like the bubbles and like that's like
the traditional way to make yourself a
nice flat cup of matcha but because
that's a lot of work for me I actually
just whisk it with the froth there so I
I just used this thingy that I use with
my coffee as well and then I get my nice
frothy matcha someone makes them right
now nice hot cup of delicious ceremonial
matcha from Jun be great way to start
the day and then also some quick much
effects in case you guys didn't know
which makes me really love logic matcha
actually helps whiten your teeth unlike
caffeine and coffee they stain your
teeth that's one thing another thing
matcha
gives you that night
clean like healthy energy boosts and it
doesn't give you that nasty crash that
coffee gives you and doesn't give you
headaches and I love it it takes so much
cleaner I try to like fully convert
myself to just matcha but sometimes I
like that I miss the coffee flavor so
I'll make myself a cup of coffee in the
morning but I am so happy and so proud
to be part of Jun be and then look we
have single serve packets too so they
comes with ten packets and you can just
prepare this anywhere you are so if you
like to dump this and a couple in a
bottle of water and then you have this
little packet and then you just like mix
it up really well and then you got your
matcha to go but I know no one's really
going anywhere these days so yeah you
can get yourself a Tendo right there
there'll be a link in the description
and you guys can shop for your own Juby
matcha and yes we do ship
internationally so you can check out and
taste your own matcha and make your own
matcha at home
and then every time I sip it I'm always
like oh it's making my teeth whiter okay
let's get started on this wallpaper
project oh and then also look how cute
the cup and the matcha totally matches
the wallpaper that was unplanned I like
it though oh it's okay good okay bye
okay
so update I could not start this project
because another project happened which
is the blinds the blinds people came in
a grant it was actually two people I
thought it was just gonna be one guy but
when they came they both had masks on
the whole time they had gloves and I
kept a very far distance probably like
more than six feet I think at certain
points but yeah look we got a blinds
there's nice and pretty so these are
called zebra blinds and so the reason I
wanted these is because it actually like
filters in the light and it's like this
but it's not want to completely close it
just go like that
and then full privacy yay not a breath
and then also if I want to just fully
put the blinds up I can do that too all
the way up all the way up well how does
that song go I'm going all the way up
oh there's also another project to have
today which is putting this guy up on
that glass so we can have full privacy
throughout the entire house now and then
oh my gosh it was so funny so we're
gonna get this thing installed the guy
who was crazy he actually got a ladder
oh and by the way I extended this to be
the full thing anyway we got rid of all
this he put a ladder right here up to
that ledge and him and the girl I was
freaking awkward because it's like dead
silent here and
the bedroom my hair so I could hear
everything I they were saying and the
guy he was kind of rude you think to the
girl anyway in the beginning he was
saying oh yeah don't worry cuz the girl
was like um this is scary have you done
this before and the guy was like I have
done it a million times like don't even
worry like countless times the girl was
like okay so then she's helping him
she's the one holding onto the ladder as
he's like attempting to go and he's
standing on the ladder and then the
girls like um maybe you should crawl on
it because like it distributes the
weight more evenly and it won't be so
shaky and the guy was such a jerk he's
like uh crawling that makes no sense
only an idiot would be crawling why
would you be crawling like if you know
so much why don't you do it and like he
was just so mean to her and I'm like I'm
like in the room like anyway he ended up
trying like attempting the first time
and then he got too scared and then the
girl was like well I'm not gonna do it
are you gonna beam up from my bed
medical bills if I break my neck or
something he's like fine I'll do it you
don't want to do it like I got the vibe
from them that she was like his
assistant like he's the one that is the
one that's supposed to do it so I'm like
why are you being such a jerk to her
anyway they tried putting the stairs I
mean the ladder on the stairs
and obviously like the there type of
ladder it wasn't adjustable where one
set of the legs could be shorter than
the other so it was like there's no way
that that was gonna work so then he
attempts it again and then this time
he's like okay fine so he ended up just
doing it and it got accomplished the
blinds are up but the whole time I'm
sitting there and I'm like what's this
dude's problem because she kept trying
to help him around throughout the whole
house and the he'd be like give me that
no like just give me the anything he'd
be like cursing at her and I'm like dude
chill out and it wasn't even the type of
relationship where I'm like maybe
they're together it's like family
business or like like maybe they're
really good friends I don't know like it
just gave me that vibe of like he's an
abusive superior and I just felt for the
girl I was like dude I'm sorry but
anyway positivity here we got our blinds
up so for the master bedroom I got these
blackout kind and then they're kind of
brown and shimmery and stuff
once they're fully closed you're
supposed to be sort of blackout and it's
not completely black out blacked out
which I'm perfectly okay with because I
like having some light when I sleep
because I'm big ol baby and I still get
scared of the dark lines and then over
here the blinds
oh yeah forgot to throw this away let me
show you the other two rooms so Isaac's
room got the blinds so for Isaac's room
and for the office slash spare room I
decided to get like a silver so use the
color of these two rooms and these are
also blackout blinds because the Sun
like the majority of time comes from
this corner over here so this room and I
have explained tend to get pretty hot so
that's the reason why I was like okay
it's really important that these rooms
get blackout like yay we got him we got
him so the color matches your fur I got
them because of you you know just
kidding but yeah let's just pretend that
it was cuz of you oh yeah I'm so happy
we finally have blinds come on okay so
haven't eaten breakfast without Casey
around I'm like it's gonna fade how am I
gonna survive I'm gonna I'm gonna starve
to death without my mans to feed me yeah
I'm gonna fix up some food right now and
then get started on the stairs or maybe
I should do the window first cuz and
that's easier and that's I could just be
like done done so okay window next and
then the stairs
[Music]
all right what do we think oh yeah so
remember how I complain last time about
the film that I put on the upstairs
windows and I said it was so impossible
to do properly because I didn't have the
proper tools well I ordered a kit on
Amazon and I got a whole bunch of this
stock and I got like two exacto knives
and this blade and this really cool tool
that allowed me to cut this with ease so
this made my job so much easier so I
highly recommend you getting a kit like
this if you're trying to do film on your
windows it saves you so many so many
headaches I'm so proud of this they came
out really really nice whoo so all the
cut all the windows are now fully
covered I laid out the rug here wood so
this rug is a machine washable so I kept
seeing ads on it on Instagram and it's
called ruggable not sponsored but I wish
please if you want to sponsor me there's
so many more rugs I need a buddy so but
yeah I ended up testing this one axe I'm
like let me see if I like it and it's so
good it's like really good quality and
like you couldn't like bunch it up
really small and then put it in the
washer because it comes with like the
actual carpet and then a pad so I don't
know I'm pretty happy with it just for
this like the immediate trial here or
I'm using it so the reason why I laid
out the rug is because since we took out
this other couch it has been a lot more
echoey in here so this it's still kinda
echoey I don't know if you guys can tell
but I can definitely tell it's still
kind of echoey but it has helped muffle
it so I put it down here in the meantime
hey I just realized the TV stand hasn't
came in yet you're supposed to come in
today what the heck
I know I gotta call them okay now for
the fun stuff all right well that took
an entire day and a half to complete
because now that's the next day and I am
done oh my goodness I love it so much I
could just die look at this huh it looks
so fun I am so happy with it oh how cute
this project was intense
and I made a lot of mistakes I learned a
lot but it's done and I am so happy with
it I can't wait for KC to get home and
see the finished results because last
night I just thought that the first two
steps and then I didn't even to the side
so man this is a painting but I was
trying to match up the pattern exactly
so like it looks like it curves around
it that was really difficult but I did
it I'm so proud of myself
as I was doing this and Christina they
stopped by and it was really cute
because oh they came and they dropped
off a whole bag of avocados we got a ton
of avocados now and so as I was working
on the stairs I was like Oh guys like
come down and like just peek through cuz
we can't you know social distancing we
can't be really close so I was like wait
over here
and they weren't like at the front of
the gate and they were just like oh it
looks great like a king but I'm like man
decides I want a hug
like say hi to Leia and Enzo cuz they're
getting bigger every day but yeah that
was really cute and then oh by the way
the TV stamp came today so I kept
thinking it was supposed to come
yesterday like when this video started
but no it was today so it's here now I
gotta move all those boxes and fit the
TV stand there I feel so accomplished
like I'm so freaking happy this looks so
good
and then remember how I was saying how
like the patterns didn't really match up
between the two roles well you can't
really tell cam eeeh you can't at all
I love it oh my god I love it I love it
I love it okay and open your eyes
conclusion totally transformed the
stairs do you like it oh my goodness
we're going to the jungle yeah so fun
now mhmmm a fun staircase that's what I
said I think it looks so fun let's have
dinner here
[Music]